yeah so my talk is building a data
pipeline from scratch I recently had
this interesting opportunity while
recent is about ten months ago to move
on to under startup project Florida or
working with a team to help build out a
data pipeline from scratch so going to
kind of give a overview based on
experience there and experience at
Foursquare and at Konan which was
I'd network that I were dad when I first
started getting into
the big data to those types of
infrastructure products really got into
data pipelines
the overview of this talk and please
feel free to interrupt me we're pretty
small group if you guys have questions
or need clarification or anything just
let me know to talk about why we should
care about data pipelines and locate the
top
give-give my brief definition and get a
pipeline and talk about events which are
a good way of thinking about the data
and pipeline and talk a little bit about
systems how can I spend up a lot of time
going into all the really technical
details of writing a MapReduce job or
deploying these systems or anything like
that
but I'm happy to answer questions about
them
ten cups
so the main premise I have here is that
data pipelines are everywhere and I want
to motivate that with some examples
I wrote probably see in both of these
screens the Amazon recommended products
the LinkedIn people you may know
they're both bill about data pipelines
that take in click events few events
and there's some magic sauce happening
and spitting out recommendations
ad networks are another big place that
data pipelines are used take it clicks
or add impression to build a user
profile that can then be used to
which adds to show you
searched a lot of the products that are
in open source now are are built on
papers and research products that were
originally done at Google to help
support search page rank is the kind of
main algorithm that most you will
probably heard of where you take in this
graph of all the pages on the internet
and use that to help rank search results
AP testing pretty hot topic recently
it's where you bucket users into two
groups and maybe one group gets a coupon
and the other group gets free shipping
and then you try to measure the outcome
the bottom line how much which group is
generates more revenue for the company
and in this case you would be taking in
conversion data which is basically how
much money to spend and you can then
decide which group A or B fun shipping
to go
did a warehousing this idea of building
datasets for analytics about what's
happening with your user base you've
probably seen things like tableau which
should build these shiny interfaces to
let you explore your data break it down
by geography drill in and see how users
are interacting with certain features
these are typically backed by a data
warehouse
you're putting the key event about a key
metrics different user events on to a
data pipeline doing some magic and
creating your data warehouse
so I took a stab at defining what a date
of pipeline is it's probably not the
best appreciate but it's fine
and definition is that a data pipeline
is a unified system for capturing events
for analysis and building products so we
just talked about all these different
examples but you could think about a
setup where you use you power all these
different features or some subset of
them by taking in all these different
user actions putting them on a data
pipeline
and then using that data pipeline to
build all those features all those your
data warehouse and also support ad hoc
analysis that you can do before
nor would they repeat the definition
because I use this term event and I
think event which is kind of the
primitive of your data pipeline
something that we should talk a bit more
about
so things like a click and a depression
opening your app
double screen these are all actions over
events
I think a lot of people doing these
kinds of analysis start with what I'm
calling coarse-grained events so
you are running Apache or running nginx
or some web server and it's generating
log files or maybe you're even
generating your own log files typically
these are sorted in text logs and it's
the primary use is to
debug things to figure out what's going
wrong you know when when you're having
errors or maybe doing some operational
monitoring and then they're secondarily
is for that analysis if you if you're
you know more technical if you've
probably seen a line like this and a lot
of file at some point you have some IP
addresses with the timestamp loading
some website and that would is the type
of coarse-grain event that I'm talking
about
and from this coarse-grained event you
can do something implicit tracking so
the example I'm going to use is you have
an event called get the news feed get
sloshed news feed
and that would be a single line in your
log file
but this actually could correspond to a
lot of events if it's the first time
that that endpoint has been accessed in
that user session and that probably
means it's an apple bit if you're doing
an a/b test on your newsfeed it's an
implicit entry of the user into the a
group or the B group of
a Vitesse and you can go on and on and
we have this situation or I've seen the
situation aquatic Pines and what ends up
happening is we've all this application
logic to fill to generate the response
for the slash news feed and when you
want to do analysis you don't have to
redo all of that logic you have to look
and see if it was the first session the
the first request of the session to
figure out if it means it was an app
open and then you have to recreate the
the user ID hashing logic to figure out
which group the user was in so a lot of
companies have have written a lot about
what they're doing to turn this problem
around so instead of course great events
we're going to log find great events and
what this generally means
is that instead of having a single event
you loaded the news feed you have
several events anything that's relevant
an apple bin maybe the user the Newspeak
was it was loaded because it was a
pulldown and not a refresh or enter into
an ami test all these different things
you would log as you generate events for
and there could be more than one event
usually is more than one of them for a
single API
and you can also annotate the events
with a lot of information we're kind of
denormalizing your schema you put as
much information about the user about
the context of where the event happened
in your app on the website as is
necessary for analysis
and what's really great is that this
decouples logging analysis rather than
having to recreate that logic oh if it
was the first time the news feed was was
accessed in this session that means it
was an app open you just have an event
that says applicant so you're not tied
to the business logic that you'd
implemented in your application when
you're doing announces
um
in terms of events event logging I
talked about the you know the HTTP
apache style logging one text entry per
line a lot of people uh you want to go
to this event based approach the first
thing you do is use JSON reviews CSV and
well that's better than meeting a regex
to parse share access logs it has a lot
of the few drawbacks it's a lot harder
to change schemas if you have a CSV all
you can do is add new columns on the
ends it it's pretty inefficient if
you're generating billions of these
events per day and for each event your
own
you bet you're running it through tens
of jobs you're parsing JSON tens of
times and you probably compressed your
JSON files pretty heavily because the
scroll JSON is really for both there's
now you have to pay the overhead of CPU
to decompress the data and on top of
that if you have to encode this logic
about schema migrations or you know
changes to the data or your partial
object
and that means your your partial now
have to write something in Python it's
in Java you need to
so
again the big internet startups kind of
paved the way talking about schemas
further their event data Google
introducing protobufs Facebook Facebook
introducing threat the technologies
don't matter the idea though is that you
have a schema that defines your data and
the schema is putting a contract saying
that you you know my data will have
these fields and each field will have a
certain type and it provides a mechanism
to add new types of fields to your data
because you can connect schema version 1
and schema version 2
as long as you're doing non-destructive
changes to the schema version to can
read version 1 and the schema does a lot
of nice things in addition to just
making things more efficient providing
guarantees about what fields are there
it helps you do a lot of automated
analytics I'm going to talk a little bit
about this unified logging paper that
came out of Twitter and I think it's a
good way of understanding the benefits
of the schema so they show Twitter they
generate events for everything yes they
have a lot of tweets they've a lot
they also have a lot of event data about
higher interacting with the application
and they use the same schema to generate
events whether you're on Android you're
on iOS you're on the website and every
event has has certain fields like your
you know user ID session ID time Stan
but it also has this this powerful idea
called an event name and up here these
are the parts of an event name it's
really that idea of annotating an event
with the context about it so for example
if I fire up Twitter I go from the home
screen click on the mentions tab click
on a tweet button I'm like Jenner
generate an event with this name
on the analytic side if I wanted to
count how many clicks were being from
the home screen on iPhone I would just
match events with that name
or if I wanted to count across all
devices I could use this regular
expression and that does a lot for ad
hoc analysis but you can also think
about generating reports by instead of
just using a wild card can you grow by
the device the the client type so you
would get a account for iPhone you get
an account for web you get a count for
Android and you can generate these by
moving the asterisks around that main
different level so you can start all the
way at the right and move your way back
and you get larger and larger numbers as
you go so it's a good way to build
roll-ups if you're familiar with data
warehouses
okay so we talked about motor food
motivation one of the data pipeline is a
little bit about events schemas and and
now I'm going to get into more technical
details about the systems in a datatype
line and give a few recommendations
about the technologies and tools that I
I am planning on using or I would
recommend using if if you were to
started by planting scratch
so the first one is event framework you
know we talked about how you have a
request coming in you might be
generating several events for that
request so you need a mechanism that
makes it easy to generate these events
so it's something like bow then is my
then
I just say then logged out log event and
that magically prints the event into the
data pipeline
maybe ads annotations based on what's in
the requests automatically so it should
be really easy to generate these events
and if it's really easy to generate
these events then you're probably going
to generate a lot of them so the second
requirement is a really big message bus
these can you can't afford a truck with
this through a single machine you also
probably can't afford to lose data of
one machine fell so you need horizontal
scalability redundancy and you need a
system that's easy to as good API as for
submitting data and also getting data
back out and there are a bunch of these
their scribe that was built at Facebook
there's Apache chunk one of theirs and
patchy flu and there's my personal
favorite Apache Kafka and there are
other queueing systems the difference
between other queueing systems like
rabbit or 0q and knees is that these
systems are going to be really well
integrated into the next step in your
data pipeline which is a data
persistence layer so you have all these
events coming in or you generate all
these events from your application
you're putting them all in the big
message bus now you need to persist them
somewhere so that
do ad hoc analysis you can do historical
reports on your data and really the only
two solutions unless you're working at
Google are to use Hadoop the reduced
distributed file system or or Amazon s3
I guess you know there OpenStack has an
API compatible s3 there's Google compute
engine which also has a KPI compatible
version investing area and then you need
some toilet to get data into your
persistence layer these are two tools
that the kite software development came
in spring to do that encapsulate a lot
the best practices about
get a message across to your sister
Claire third or fourth I guess you need
to a workflow management solution
because you're going to be point data
allegory running a report on it and
automate the fashion generated vlogs to
put into your data warehouse running
your recommendation engine over the data
to spit out today's recommendations so
you need a way to represent the
dependencies between these parts of the
data pipeline and to coordinate them and
there are a couple of open-source
solutions there's Luigi from Spotify
there's Busey which came out a Yahoo
there's an Azkaban I cannot elect it
and workflow management is one of these
things that it seems like it's a really
general problem and there should be a
really good general solution to it and
my experience has been that if you know
an overly general workflow object that's
really hard to use so I think underrated
is the option of building your own
system to manage your workflows
but if I had to make a recommendation
today me too
I really like that as more polenta and
then last we talked about this the
schemas and events and you need a
serialization framework which takes an
event and the schema for that event and
turns it into bytes on disk and there
are a lot of options
in terms of civilization frameworks I'm
going to talk about a few that are very
well integrated into the Duke ecosystem
they are Apache Avro patchy drift and
protocol buffers and again if you ask me
to pull my own system using one of these
technologies that we're going to use
match ever
so now you have your Cheryl sterilized
data persistent storage just need to do
your your batch processing things like
to do to do MapReduce jobs that are
running over tons of Tom's gigabytes
terabytes terabytes of data or Apache
hive or some other SQL on Hadoop
solution to run ad-hoc analysis over
data so MapReduce is a framework for
running for radiant distributed jobs but
it's verbose you have to there are only
two operations you can do on the data
map or reduce so you want to use a tool
like hi too bright either sequel or some
other you know higher-level language on
top of MapReduce and those systems
translate a sequel query into a
MapReduce job or
whoa - a microbrew strong and if you put
it all together this is kind of what I'm
envisioning so like I said you know data
logging framework so that you can really
easily generate events you have a data
serialization framework to convert your
schema your data with its schema to
bytes on this which you put in your
message bus eventually making their way
to persistent storage and this is going
to be event data might have things like
user IDs instead of full user objects so
you need a dump all of your production
databases to join the two together for
your actual application data warehousing
the workflow engine kind of ties
everything together and this is a really
really powerful platform like I said
these were the the systems that I would
use if I started from scratch but really
the important thing is to use something
don't you know reinvent the wheel all
these there's a plethora of great
open-source tools so now they give a
data pipeline in in place there are a
lot of things you can do with it that
you couldn't do before so you're putting
events onto your message bus and
basically real time you know maybe
within 100 milliseconds or something
like that
so rather than so you have one
subscriber that puts the data persistent
storage but now you can
build another subscriber using Apache
storm or one of these near time
processing frameworks that pulls data
off the message bus and those near time
calculation so maybe you want to so one
example going back to Twitter yet again
is they have that that button that you
can embed that says how many times this
article has been tweeted right so
they're subscribing to a data pipeline
and updating those counts and near
real-time so that white now someone who
owns the page you can talk to back-end
that retrieves the accounts
you can also do things like share
information between services if you you
know a user just saw an ad or just
clicked on an ad you might put that
event in your message bus and then the
optimization system in your ad network
could take that into account for the
next time that user is seen so that
maybe you don't show the user the
have a better idea of what they see
message buses are really good at taking
data in and putting it out so it's
really easy to hook them together to
take data from one data center and copy
it to another data center which is
something that is becoming more and more
common even in startups you need some
redundancy because Amazon is not always
the most reliable call nor sorry about
that tuition and the lambda architecture
is something that ties
near time processing together with your
batch process
Nathan Lars used the creator of storm
propose this lambda architecture and the
idea is that you have a batch process
that runs once a day or every couple of
hours and it uses your persistent data
the data that you know is correct to
build the baseline the best note value
your counts or your user profile and
then between those batch jobs you have a
real-time system that is subscribing to
this message bus and is doing an
incremental update and then when a
request comes in its going to consult
the data set that was built by the batch
processing framework and also the data
that might have been updated or
generated by your real-time framework
and the reason you do this batch
processing at the end of every day is
that it's really hard to get your time
processing correct every message queue
says that they have certain delivery
guarantees but it turns out there are
almost always failure scenarios where
your message bus delivers duplicates or
something get sacked and
data was actually process
Gio's want to use the bachelor to the
first correct this one goes off
and that brings us basically to the end
of what I had to say about data
pipelines I mean I didn't get into all
the technical details because I could
spend days talking about each of these
components of the system
what I was hoping to give everyone a
good overview based on my experience
and yeah these are some of the key
takeaways data pipelines are everywhere
it's really powerful to think of data as
events instead of it lies in a log file
and this premise of unified data
pipeline is really useful
don't go building all this yourself
their money
it's really a matter of taking the piece
the puddle puzzle putting them
great waves
and most of these ideas in this talk are
not my own it's just kind of a processed
what other people are doing I mean I
certainly have experience with these
with these systems and I know what
doesn't work I know what has worked well
so far but a lot of the experience I
gained was based on other people's hard
work so
check out some of these
these papers and slides
I'm
they won
so yeah so the question was how did you
test the data pipeline
there are a couple of solutions the best
one and this is usually not a popular
one is that here your pipeline should be
considered a core piece of the
application and if for some reason
sending an event to your message bus
fails it should fail the request
that's the best way to know that you're
capturing everything it is it's not a
popular one because people say well if I
fail an ad impression and I'm losing
money but there's really unless you feel
that impression there's a bad you know
people probably aren't going to fix the
problem it becomes something that
doesn't get the bug to get shoved under
the carpet there are other options like
we force where we had a kind of phantom
event topic so every application server
always sent some fake event every 30
seconds or something like that and you
giving a word if an obligation server
that was alive didn't create an event
you can have you know just having an
having metrics in place so they
incremented color when
ensure all
but yeah the the owner really foolproof
way is well you have to have your your
message bus set up and tested the
failure scenarios and have confidence in
that and then tailor request unless your
data against them to to your
constituents then maybe you'll have a
rough 24 hours but you know
we sort out those issues it's gonna be
rock-solid
sure
what message one
sure so the question is what's the
plugins more about the message bus and
what the purpose of that is so there are
a couple purposes the first is that you
want to have
you don't want to do event processing in
a synchronous way
so you wouldn't want to on the request
path persist an event directly to your
persistent storage because maybe there's
a problem with the network and you can't
talk to the persistent storage or you
know you're talking to s3 so you're
doing another each of you request s3 or
gets you a mess so you definitely want
to
do some local buffering before the
persistence or so so you could buffer
that to local disk but then you now have
this massive problem how do I get data
from all the local disks to my
persistent storage so kind of push the
problem around but the the main reason
you want this message boss sees
it's a powerful primitive persistent
storage is just one of the
use cases of the message bus the others
are near time processing they can pull
events off to do update counters in real
time you can use it to communicate
information in an asynchronous is a
couple way between different services in
your back-end it really opens up a lot
of possibilities for for processing
principal snare
while
for all of those
those logs will shoot and sir
the one
yeah so it's a message boss what'd you
think about did with events as a
permitted not log files so you are the
way something like Apache Kaka or patchy
flu works is that you're you're doing an
RPC from your application put data into
the message box you're not writing into
a local disk unless there's a frenetic
failure scenario in the network so
you're generating events and each event
is being put into the message bus in
near-real-time
the latency typically is you know a
couple milliseconds or maybe
- you completely bypassed the local risk
I mean if you're generating these events
in the way that I'm saying you're going
to need a pretty massive local desk in
order to to buffer them all
so that's another
you love learning curve so
for example this slide
a cow inside of the box
today run
so a lot of configuration
yeah so talking about the learning curve
and configuration
let's see so
there's definitely you know it's it
there's definitely something that's it
you know generating events that are a
borough serialize is more work than
generating JSON put the bet with each of
these systems is that I would say even
in the medium term term you're going to
you're going to gain efficiency
something like Kafka is super easy to
set up in deploy you've got really good
docks it's it's not doing anything
clever in the JVM it's just copying
bytes from the network to the disk and
let us do all the caching so you don't
have to tune any of that stuff
and Luigi in terms of workflow engine
that's the one that is definitely the
easiest to get going and persistent
storage I mean s3 you have s3 data
warehouse there's Amazon redshift if
you're Amazon so like its couple clicks
to set up a data warehouse it's it's
definitely work and it's the kind of
thing that you don't want to tackle it
all at once
you wanna do things incrementally so
maybe you get a logging framework in
place first and it's still generating
JSON you're still you know using the
same mechanism table it
Avro is actually nice because it's
compatible JSON so you can have it
serialize to JSON instead of too opaque
bytes so infuriating that you can still
use
yes others there's a learning curve but
I would say that it does pay off in the
medium term
especially if you're building their
products on your data
it's so much easier to build products on
your data if you
well form schemas your
getting new persistent storage reliably
all these things that I did
couple things just along the same lines
first of all are you aware of anything
that
those try to deliver this whole thing
package and I backed up view low on top
like something out of the box cities
pieces so all these pieces out box
pretty close so Amazon has a system
called
it's called Kinesis
everyone so it was not as qisas which is
basically a big message bus and then
they've also given you the logging
framework so they've implementations of
Java their limitations in Ruby Python
what-have-you and they also have a
system to persist data into s3 from from
pieces it's not going to give you the
data serialization it also has a Amazon
as a workflow engine that you can use to
load data into their data warehouse I
mean I think you're going to start to
see all these
infrastructure-as-a-service folks doing
this and
there's cloud sac which is kind of the
open-source implementation of these
systems and there are a couple of years
behind but though
they'll catch up you can only pay people
to help you deploy this system there are
a lot of enterprise services that will
and I haven't much
with what the green endpoints me a
monitoring collection platform flag
brown fibers
so what the one of the end points be
graphite birth out over go hey it could
be um so what we did for square was we
didn't do put our operational metrics
into this pipeline mostly because there
it's just a different granularity you
don't have it's just basically a number
and a value
what we did do is we used graphite in
herre learning systems to sanity check
the outputs of the jobs our work for so
look we ran you know an ingestion job
every day and if we ingested vastly
different amounts of data and today that
we did yesterday and that probably means
something went wrong either we lost a
lot of data or we generated duplicate
data or something so you would kind of
push those metrics to graphite but it
was you know not not the finder in stone
the maintenance of the Navy so for the
long run
yeah yeah so I mean I think the if we
look at like what Twitter did they you
know they're trying to namespace things
but yes this one Allah was talking
earlier there's more than to our
problems in computer science is maybe
things oh I think having this FEMA homes
but I don't I don't have a great
solution
yeah
um so which was that that was yeah so
well I should matter yes well it's I
would say it's super easy to build your
on but there are a lot of components
that you can use are been frameworks
your pipeline their event frameworks for
Java spring batch is a big one so if
there are these components that make it
fairly easy to go your own
I would say I would say that starting
with something like Luigi is probably
your best bet but if you have so to
something like Busey is meant to be this
very generic workflow system and one of
the ways they made a generic was that
they said okay we don't want you to have
to define your work clothes as code
you're going to use XML to the finder
workflows and you end up with these
levels of indirection that make it hard
to the bug once the thing goes wrong but
you also have support for everything
under the Sun that you could ever do
with a workflow engine you're probably
using some small slice of that and the
small slice you're using there's
probably something that the workflow
correct and if you want to and then so
now you're like okay well I'll just I'll
just fix the work for lunch and it could
be that hard that you know and you look
at the source code and you're like wow
so one of the things I like about Luigi
actually is that it's very easy it's
written in Python it's very easy to to
hack on if you have a problem you want
to add a new type of task it's it's
really simple permanent
and that's why you should be gotten for
work here
your if your filter
well done
people consuming
results of this so ultimately very sir
how do you communicate
you know changes do
yeah so that's a good question how do we
know how do you document what the
intricacies of the data okay we had a
bug on this day values
what does disappear
no there's a great solution to that what
I've seen
fourscore oh we had a tool for doing
that hog analysis we built a wiki into
that so that you could go in and
annotate feels tables fields and data
sets
right that chair that their main
knowledge that the person implementing
it but a lot of times
a question will come in what does this
field mean or how do I get at this data
the only solution was to go and get the
source code and that was very much when
we were in a situation where we're using
the coarse grain ball game but once you
get to once you start doing - fine
grained logging it does solve a lot of
these problems because you don't have to
deduce things about the data it's
generated event that says app open
you're not saying all right what you
know what are the different situations
that could represent an appelgren or
homepage
in our data yeah they're definitely
subtlety it feels like a wiki is a
really good way it's all that I don't
know a better yet this happens
then we're on
so I
portal
laughs because
I've been
the world
right not to
rather than work
but the fact that there
I'm
sneaking different problem
maybe
that I see of the neck
I would be about
Bravo unit
again starting from images work
and more
it's like doing a couple
they called you
yeah so I'll talk about the first
question on a dog analysis so in terms
of like big data tools this is like the
biggest growth area right now everyone
is generating or building a new school
on do sequel on s3 solution so there
there are tons Facebook has one called
presto caldera has Impala
there's Apache hi I mean there's a whole
website you can time it up one of my
former colleagues actually wrote it got
a good plug good blog post that
summarizes some of these if you don't
like sequel there are other solution
this is given how many more
really
yeah so that's a good way to see in
these tools so like I said go to the
message bus it's tunable so for already
okay yeah yeah so for the wind see for
analysis again things are moving really
quickly it used to be on order of point
your simplest query it's going to take
at least five minutes but but now I
think a lot of the tools are down to
over you know a second or two
yeah if you have I don't think you'll
see light on s3 you'll see it if you
rotate in the red ship you'll see if you
are running one of the see what I do on
a big cluster that has distributed
yeah for the so if I understand that
question right you you're talking about
how you have this dependency graph
between all the different data sets and
if like one of the you know your your
graph and if one of the items over on
this side changes they kind of triple
cheese yeah we know I don't have a great
solution that one thing that I have
we definitely run into this problem with
big data sets it in some ways it it can
be a bigger problem because if one of
your route dataset changes maybe that
takes 10 hours to recompute and then
everything down from that just gets
delayed and actually get into a spiral
where you don't catch up but one of the
things we played around with was these
data's are stored in directories in your
file system
and putting a version number in
some kind of namespacing living a
version number in the TAF and if you are
work for a tool if you're using
something like Luigi is is a smart
enough to know about these version
numbers you can actually have a
regenerate all downstream data for you
I mean
what
that's my understands well yeah yeah I
don't know that there's a good solution
to that another arson graph processing
frameworks I don't know what they would
fit this problem
yep how do you think about the trade-off
between performance degradation and
general
like what's the right way under
yeah the sort of trade-off between log
data and
like michael accurate everything doesn't
use it but I'm assuming that comes at a
cost or the office either on your web
app or in some packing service that's
generating that event
starting over
all that
at some point I'm assuming that pick
yeah real arm
there's a couples so in practice I don't
know that I think would be hard to hit
that one it
so first of all like the clients that
are logging framework confusing most of
these systems are going to be smart
they're there they're going to batch
stuff up hopefully they're going to
they're getting compressed data before
they
fire so there's there's a
oh that's kind of getting around your
answer but in practice or getting around
your question but practice Lee
you can log a lot and it's not going to
cause you from decorations now there are
systems like so there's a system called
zip kit which is a distributed tracing
framework so if you
a request coming in and it talks to all
these backends it will generate an event
whenever a request comes in or requests
comes out and that does your talking
hundreds of
events per request and that will hurt
performance and what they do there is
sample but that's for operational
you can scale this
yeah yeah it's a good question so wait
so so those that don't know they're
there any systems like logstash there's
on commercial tools chemical enables
spunk yeah
so those systems they you know you have
lots of applications output involves the
central idea what you query them and
these types of things to search for a
needle in a haystack bar to do
aggregations I think I would teach you
things about that the first is that
those are typically more operational so
you might have run those in parallel to
you to your your message books and I do
think some people do that so that's one
thing
the second is there our search on Duke
is a very big topic right now so like I
say before if you use Avro there's a
JSON representation you can serialize
your events to JSON and what they've
done is they've integrated solar cloud
solar is it search indexing system sort
of hoppers a distributed version of it
and what it does is it builds up search
indexes very similar like what logs I
had on top of your data summation pass
him because a the an Avro file is self
describing it knows what the schema of
the data is and diverting the JSON use
all the same very functionality
from logs - it's just going to be on
your events not on requests or whatever
operational quality
you're
well so that that brings me to my ship
most plug I run a million West culpa
Duke weekly and if you go there I have
archives and I think it was about this
is past Sunday but the Sunday before
word my colleagues overview on 10 sq all
systems sometimes
would you say
so question is ad-hoc analysis and data
warehouse are the same I think you
should strive to enter 90% of your ad
hoc analyses with your data warehouse
but there's going to be 10% where you
need to go over raw data where you need
to
apply a function that you can't
represent in a data warehouse or you
need to reuse your business logic from
your application to do it I think there
there's a 10% where you need to go over
the raw data and do some some custom or
maybe you're joining another data set
situations that probably not words
wise
see
yeah so that I think there's two things
if you want to add a new metric it's
going to be really easy to write a
MapReduce job to build that you know the
long term the historic back flow for
that we did that all time for square the
second though is it's someone asking for
that metric because they want to ask one
question and that's going to be the only
question they ever ask of that metric or
is it something that they need all the
time and if it's something that they
only need to answer one question one
time then you can use to do that
analysis save yourself a lot of thanks a
lot thanks for the question is great